[Musica]
vi ricordate quando al culmine della
pandemia
qualcuno ha cominciato a dire che ne
saremmo usciti migliori io ci ho creduto
veramente ho cominciato a crederci il
giorno in cui il premier albanese edi
rama ha fatto quel bel discorso
incentrato sulla riconoscenza quando
l'albania ha inviato 30 sanitari tra
medici infermieri per sostenere il
sistema sanitario lombardo che era al
collasso un discorso incentrato sulla
riconoscenza che ci ha proiettato
indietro di 30 anni a quello che
chiamavamo il grande esodo albanese a
giorni come questo
l'otto agosto del 1991 e la nave vlora
arriva il porto di bari con circa 20.000
migranti a bordo non c'è mai stato uno
sbarco più grande con un'unica
imbarcazione nella storia del nostro
paese
non fu una passeggiata fu un emergenza
difficile da gestire ma l'italia seppe
tendere la mano per questa di rama ha
parlato di riconoscenza ed è un discorso
che ha avuto l'apprezzamento di tutti
allora ho pensato guarda con me l'italia
e l'albania guardano il proprio passato
guardandosi indietro con serenità e
distacco in un momento difficile per il
nostro paese
se questo può succedere allora davvero
potremo uscirne migliori poi questo
valzer delle illusioni è finito quando
nel pieno dell'estate si sono accesi
alcuni focolai di coronavirus in alcune
città del nostro paese abbiamo
cominciato ad addossare la
responsabilità di quanto stava accadendo
ai migranti arrivati a lampedusa tra
l'altro tutti sottoposti a tampone il
regime di quarantena anche quando
l'istituto superiore di sanità nel suo
bollettino del 14 agosto ha detto che i
contagi dei migranti incidevano in una
microscopica parte per quanto riguardava
i contagi generali questa convinzione ha
fatto fatica a perdere vigore
allora è qui che è nata la mia voglia di
reazione vorrei che questo momento di
angoscia sicuramente non punto non solo
da un punto di vista sanitario ma anche
per quel che riguarda il nostro lavoro
la preoccupazione economica e certamente
non si traducesse come già successo in
altre epoche buie della storia in odio
in discriminazione nei confronti dei
diversi delle minoranze delle persone
che hanno meno diritti come il diritto
alla libertà di movimento che è sancita
dalla dichiarazione universale dei
diritti dell'uomo non tutti abbiamo la
stessa libertà di movimento mi aiuto con
questo sito internet qualcuno di voi lo
conoscerai passport index e stila la
classifica dei passaporti più potenti al
mondo ovvero quei passaporti che non
necessitano di un visto particolare per
entrare nella maggior parte dei 200
paesi dei quasi 200 paesi delle nazioni
unite
cosa vuol dire più potenti lo dico in
altre parole che non necessitano di un
visto prima della partenza e una volta
che arriva a destinazione basta
compilare un modulo in testa questa
classifica ci sono sempre paesi ricchi
industrializzate all'inizio di questo
2020 c'era il giappone per esempio per
quanto riguarda l'europa sempre nelle
prime posizioni sono la germania la
francia la svizzera anche e anche
l'italia ha un passaporto molto potente
siamo sempre tra i quattro i primi
cinque molto potente poi è successo
qualcosa è successo qualcosa lo sappiamo
all'inizio di quest'anno è arrivato
questo virus della cina è il primo paese
a essere colpito in occidente è stato
l'italia bullish neppure a capire che
cosa stesse realmente accadendo
poi l'abbiamo capito quando mano a mano
i paesi che ci stavano attorno hanno
cominciato a chiudere i loro confini
siamo diventati in poche settimane gli
appestati d'europa respinte soli
compressi dentro i nostri confini brutto
è brutto o verso un senso di autentiche
claustrofobia eppure è la situazione che
vivono le persone dei paesi che figurano
sempre in fondo a questa classifica sono
sempre gli stessi afghanistan iraq siria
yemen somalia
hayes in guerra paesi da cui le persone
vogliono fuggire
alcune ce la fanno altre no
altre vogliono lungo il percorso sapete
quante persone sono morte nel
mediterraneo centrale dal 2014 oggi più
di 20.000 4.000 all'anno 11 al giorno
sono numeri che ci fanno riflettere
almeno fanno riflettere
buona parte di noi ma non servono non
bastano almeno a spiegarci a darci la
complessità della realtà ci servono a
inquadrare un fenomeno in maniera
complessiva ma non a darci la
complessità della realtà per quello
servono le storie i racconti fatti
immersi nel loro contesto le storie le
storie innescano una risposta emotiva
come l'amore l'odio ancora empatia
terrano storia e nel corso della mia
vita professionale ho avuto modo di
raccontare diverse storie e muovermi in
diversi paesi del mondo anche se mio
padre mi è sempre scoraggiato ogni volta
che chiama a casa per dire guarda che
domanda di qua della mio padre mi dice
dove fatto che si per i qui a casa il
padre non si è mai mosso del veneto
credo si sia mosso cinque o sei volte ma
in occasioni molto molto particolare e
forse per contrapposizione ma ho fatto
questo lavoro e mi è capitato di
incrociare storie di guerra e di
migranti e sappiamo come le cose molto
spesso siano intrecciate in afghanistan
lungo la rotta balcanica e domeni nel
campo profughi che al cavallo del 2015 è
stato uno dei campi profughi più grandi
d'europa confine tra grecia e macedonia
ancora in libano ancora nei paesi
dell'africa sub sahariana ed è una
storia che arriva dall'africa sub
sahariana dal burkina faso che voglio
raccontarvi la storia di ahmed ad hama 2
i coniugi che vivono in un villaggio nel
nord del burkina faso è anche la storia
del loro figlio che è partito con una
volontà di arrivare in europa ma è stato
ucciso probabilmente da un gruppo di
criminali o di trafficanti a colpi di
arma da fuoco
una volta arrivato in libia per essere
derubato dei pochi soldi che aveva in
tasca in libia la vita di un migrante
non vale assolutamente
nulla non sono stati privati solamente
della cosa più preziosa che è un figlio
ma sono stati privati anche di ogni
prospettiva per il futuro
ad hama passa le sue giornate a
raccogliere delle pietre a ridosso del
suo villaggio le rompe per ricavarne
della ghiaia da vendere a delle imprese
locali per un euro e 30 centesimi al
giorno è un lavoro stancante usurante
sotto il sole cocente del burkina faso e
ogni volta che penso la sua storia pensa
lei penso a mia madre perché meno la
stessa età di adam e pensa che rabbia
proverei a vederla vivere in queste
condizioni
in un periodo della vita in cui tutti
dovremmo aspirare solamente a un po di
tranquillità perché vi racconto proprio
questa storia perché mi è capitato di
incrociare le storie di adama e ahmed
seguendo come giornalista
un progetto che per me è molto
importante che non voglio dire che mi
abbia cambiato la vita perché questa una
retorica sempre un po pesante
stucchevole se vogliamo ma sicuramente
la arricchita e il nome di questo
progetto cinemarena è un progetto
realizzato dalla ex l'agenzia italiana
per la cooperazione allo sviluppo e
l'oim l'organizzazione internazionale
per le migrazioni che vuole portare nei
villaggi dei paesi a più alta densità
migratoria informazioni su quali siano i
rischi connessi all'immigrazione
irregolare e lo fa attraverso il cinema
mi aiuta o meglio con un po di immagini
siamo arriva la carovana del cinema rena
viene montato questo mega schermo e poi
quando cala la sera iniziano le
proiezioni non ci sono solamente
proiezioni di film di documentari di
cartoni animati è una grande festa per i
villaggi diciamo
portano queste informazioni villaggi
dove manca tutto a cominciare dall
energia elettrica e dicevamo è è una
festa che dura circa 2 ore con canti
balli appunto proiezioni cartoni animati
a volte viene coinvolta anche una
compagnia teatrale ovviamente
l'intrattenimento e un protesto quello
che che si vuole fare e portare queste
informazioni perché le persone che
partono da questi villaggi molto spesso
sanno poco di quello che li attende
sanno poco del deserto del cosiddetto
mare di sabbia neanche noi abbiamo
contezza esattamente di quante persone
muoiono ogni anno nel sahara o nel sel
sanno poco della libia nei campi di
prigionia delle nuove forme di schiavitù
sanno poco anche del mediterraneo perché
non è visto il mare magari vivono
l'entroterra associano l'idea del mare
l'immagine del mare a quella del fiume
che scorre vicino al loro villaggio
questo emerge dalle interviste che
vengono realizzate una volta arrivati a
lampedusa è un progetto che vuole creare
consapevolezza che non vuole dire non mi
grata perché questa deve essere sempre
una scelta libera e individuale una
scelta che deve avvenire nella piena
consapevolezza dei rischi che si possono
incontrare lungo il cammino ho
conosciuto il cinema riina nel 2007
erano in mozambico e il progetto volevo
informare la popolazione sui rischi
connessi al sesso non protetto perché
c'era e c'è un grosso problema legato
alla chivu e in quei giorni in cui il
periodo più di dieci anni fa vennero
proiettato un film di charlie chaplin la
febbre dell'oro è un film dei primi anni
venti
noi istituti siamo pronti a riconoscere
il grande genio di charlie chaplin ma
magari quel tipo di comicità risulta un
pochino datata non ridiamo più come
rideva il pubblico nel cinema degli anni
20 è invece il pubblico in questi
villaggi del mozambico davvero a tre
fratelli aveva uno sguardo così puro
così privo di sovrastrutture e
l'immagine del cinema la realtà del
cinema era talmente nuova che le loro
risate erano autentiche e io ridevo
vendendo loro ridere e quello schermo
luminoso quelle risate e quelle notti
stellate del mozambico rappresentano
ancora oggi uno dei ricordi più potenti
e romantici della mia vita anche perché
avevo la consapevolezza che si stanno
salvando vite umane in cui è stato in
quei giorni che ho detto io voglio
prendere parte a questo progetto io
voglio prendere parte a questo progetto
voglio mettere la mia esperienza al
servizio del cinema e ne ha cominciato
un percorso perché non ci si improvvisa
fare niente e dopo più di dieci anni
il 24 febbraio di quest'anno sono
partito da malpensa destinazione dakar
in senegal
qualcuno di voi si ricorderà quel giorno
era il giorno in cui in lombardia hanno
chiuso le scuole a casa mi erano
felicissimi che io partissi scene
veramente da da panico ricorda mia
compagnia seduto su una sedia che mi
guarda come hannibal lecter guarda
clarisse quando va a trovarlo nel
carcere di massima sicurezza di
baltimora solo che monica povero lo
sguardo molto più intenso di anthony
hopkins e ho detto tutto
a a prescindere da questo sono partito
chiaramente con il sostegno della mia
famiglia beninteso non si parte nel
pieno di una pandemia mondiale se non si
ha il supporto della propria famiglia
siamo arrivati a dakar ci siamo spostati
in casa march questa ragione nel sud del
senegal e abbiamo dato via alle
proiezioni abbiamo raggiunto decine di
villaggi e raggiunto anche migliaia di
persone è un bel progetto cinemarena in
grado di salvare potenzialmente migliaia
di vite umane
eppure è una goccia nell'oceano non ha
la pretesa di risolvere tutti i problemi
della del dell'africa è quasi superfluo
dirlo eppure l'italia non sembra puntare
molto su progetti di questo tipo sapete
quanto spendiamo in cooperazione
internazionale lo 0,21 per cento del pil
e sono dati riferiti al 2018 dell'ocse
allora non possiamo dire non possiamo
dire aiutiamoli a casa loro
se poi non mettiamo i soldi progetti la
visione perché rimangono slogan
assolutamente voti e di slogan vuoti non
abbiamo assolutamente bisogno ma anche
se facessimo più investimenti non
dobbiamo farne recingere tipo di fronte
un fenomeno epocale tra ieri e oggi e ci
sarà domani parliamo di immigrazione in
termini di emergenza da 30 anni 30 anni
non è un'emergenza un'emergenza qualcosa
che ti assale all'improvviso
estemporanea di secondo prima non c'era
secondo dopo c'è e tu lo sai già come
gestirla una pandemia mondiale è
un'emergenza non l'emigrazione è qui che
nasce la voglia di reagire dobbiamo
pretendere un confronto pubblico su
questo tema che sia di qualità privo di
stereotipi privo di pregiudizi un
discorso costruttivo per un argomento
che è complesso e ha ricadute sulla
nostra realtà ogni giorno ma soprattutto
sul nostro futuro non possiamo
focalizzarci sulle sbarchi a lampedusa
solo su quello non solo su quello
io non capisco come possiamo per esempio
slegare il discorso sulla questione
migratoria a quello della crisi
demografica che stiamo vivendo è uno dei
più grossi problemi che ha l'italia c'è
la l'europa ma c'era soprattutto
l'italia
siamo il paese che invecchia più
velocemente siamo quello con il maggior
numero di anziani
siamo quello con il minor numero di
nascita non dovremmo dormirci la notte
dovremo stare così con gli occhi
sbarrati
guardando il soffitto e sentire i nostri
neuroni che ci sussurrano crisi
demografica crisi demografica invece non
ne parla nessuno vi faccio vedere questi
dati
sono proiezioni al 2050 con le persone
con più di 60 anni nel nostro paese oggi
sono il 23 per cento nel 2050 saranno il
37 per cento fascia di età 0 14 anni
oggi sono il 13,5 per cento nel 2050
saranno il 10 per cento in mezzo a tutta
quella fascia di popolazione attiva che
dovrà sobbarcarsi spese pensionistiche
welfare spese sanitarie in un paese che
invecchia sempre di più e avrà sempre
più bisogno di cure mediche
altro dato fondo monetario
internazionale
oggi ci sono tra i lavoratori che
sostengono due pensionati nel 2045 ci
sarà un pensionato per ogni lavoratore
il sistema così non può reggere
dobbiamo ripensare in maniera
intelligente al nostro approccio al
fenomeno migratorio
dobbiamo ripensare a come trattiamo
questa questione e non è solo una
questione legata a questi numeri
e anche una questione è una società
fatta prevalentemente di anziani dico
prevalentemente di anziane perché le
anziane bene intesa sono molto
importanti è una società stanca una
società poco creativa e non sia stata
poco dinamica è una società poco vitale
avete mai sentito parlare di una start
up che ha dato vita un gruppo di amici
di 80 anni
no è un motivo ci sarà e anche se
qualcuno di voi mi dicesse ok allora
diamo impulso a politiche che
favoriscano la nascita nel nostro paese
giusto sacrosanto ma anche se noi
dessimo impulse a queste politiche
domani e non accadrà ma anche se lo
facessimo queste politiche avranno
effetti tra 20 25 anni troppo tardi
noi abbiamo bisogno di giovani oggi
dobbiamo ripensare le nostre politiche
migratorie oggi e voglio fare un salto
in più voglio dirvi che se vogliamo
veramente arginare i flussi regolari e
togliere quel traffico e trafficanti di
esseri umani
dobbiamo aprire i flussi regolari
dobbiamo permettere alle persone cosa
che adesso non è possibile dire veri qui
in maniera legale
magari in base a precisi parametri di
selezione delle persone in base a
necessitare il nostro mercato e lavoro
come fanno altri paesi
voglio raccontare questa storia e poi
vado a chiudere una storia che arriva
arriva dal libano ma che fare con il
canada è la storia di mike mack safadi è
un ragazzo che mi ha aiutato quando sono
andato a beirut
all'indomani dell'esplosione che ha
devastato la parte nord orientale della
città in termine giornalistico chiamiamo
queste figure fixer perché ti aiutano a
trovare contatti a trovare storie e a
muoverti in una città che conosce poco e
mike è stato davvero in gamba ma è che
lascerà il libano
questa primavera andrà in canada ha
fatto domanda domanda che è stata
accolta per il programma di migrazione
canadese che si chiama express entry è
un programma di immigrazione che va a
prendere le persone alla fonte in base a
criteri molto precisi
se vuoi non tra la domanda davis e per
le lingue che separano in canada
francese inglese
se vuoi inoltra la domanda devi avere un
lavoro che sia utile in qualche modo al
mercato del canada e mike è un agronomo
mike partirà questa primavera
allora non dico che questo debba essere
nostro modello ma meno parliamone
almeno apriamo un confronto su quello
potrà che potrebbe essere il nostro
modello
dovremo per l'immigrazione che noi
parliamo di lavoro di sanità
dall'eccessivo peso del nostro debito
pubblico invece no sono sempre
discussioni polarizzate viziate
dall'odio
dobbiamo rimettere le cose importanti al
centro lo dobbiamo più che a noi stessi
alle future generazioni ai nostri figli
agli uomini e alle donne di domani
se ce la faremo a loro sì potremmo dirci
persone migliori e io onestamente non ho
ancora perso la speranza
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]